at the center of our digital life is
java
from desktop to mobile clicks to swipes
most web applications are powered by
java
companies are competing to create the
most amazing online user experiences
leading to a great need for more java
developers
get the in-demand skills you need to
start your java developer career with
udacity's java programming nanodegree
program
you will learn by actually building web
applications ready for use in the real
world
in this nanodegree program you will
learn directly from java programming
professionals with decades of experience
by learning industry standards as you
build you can take your programming
skills to the next level
and learn how to design build and deploy
web applications
the hands-on projects and exercises in
this nanodegree program will prime you
for success
each project shows the wide application
of java in a variety of industries
you will apply your new set of java
programming skills to write
test and deploy java code feedback
is essential your projects will be
reviewed by industry professionals who
will help you develop your java skills
get ready to show your completed
projects in your portfolio with
confidence
boost your earning potential with java
enroll in udacity's java programming
nanodegree program today